Missouri man in prison for nearly two
decades for murder he did not commit his
free this morning and emotional David
Robinson walked out of prison last night
after Missouri's attorney general and
local prosecutors dismissed the charges
against him at first the Department of
Corrections refused to release him 48
hours Erin Moriarty has been closely
following this story and is here back
here again with the latest on Robinson's
difficult path to freedom when you left
the table yesterday Aaron we all said I
hope that he gets good news but it
almost didn't happen it almost didn't
two weeks ago the Missouri Supreme Court
ordered David Robinson's release but he
was still being held in prison the
Department of Correction stalled last
night saying they wanted clear direction
before releasing him
so last night Robinson's attorneys filed
an emergency motion to have him freed
and it worked
David Robinson walked out of a Jefferson
City prison on Monday night after nearly
18 years he finally got to hug his mom
as a free man it was an emotional
reunion that almost didn't happen right
here me hours before family members
waiting outside spoke with Robinson on
the phone as his attorneys worked to
have him released on Monday Robinson's
attorneys filed an emergency petition
describing his situation as a
miscarriage of justice that requires
immediate intervention I think that it's
certainly fair to say that the
institutions have failed David for the
past 17 years his release brings to an
end a legal struggle that began when he
was wrongfully convicted in the 2000
murder of Sheila box at this Sikeston
Missouri intersection in a living
nightmare
it'd been a up-and-down roller coaster
Robinson was sentenced to life without
parole on the word of two police
informants both of whom later recanted
another man romance Mosby later
confessed to the crime in 2009 Mosby
took his own life
in February a judge appointed by the
Missouri Supreme Court found that by
clear and convincing evidence David
Robinson did not kill Sheila box but is
actually
innocent of that crime even Sheila boxes
daughter crystal King agreed I believe
in my heart that he's innocent and I
stand by him now finally after nearly
two decades David Robinson is going home
it's hard not to be emotional Robinson
would not have been released had it not
been for a hard-working team of
attorneys who believed in his innocence
and offered their services free of
charge Robinson and his attorneys have
not said whether they plan to file a
lawsuit and I really should also give a
lot of credit to the Southeast
Missourian and its editor because they
did this long investigation before
anybody was looking at this case and
really kept a spotlight on it and I see
you don't want to give yourself credit
but David Robinson in an interview with
with the reporters there said that he
wanted to thank you because you
certainly gave also attention to the
story Aaron so really Bravo it's tough
to look at that story and see his tears
of joy it's a good thing but it worries
me because if we don't know about a case
how many other David Robinson's are out
there so I get letters all the time
sometimes they're hard to read and I put
them aside I worry about this all the
time last year there were 136 people who
were released after being wrongly
imprisoned so they are there are others
the appellate system has to be no one's
saying that the appellate system has to
be changed it used to be we believe that
the jury system worked perfectly now
because of DNA we know it doesn't and as
we saw in the David Robinson case it's
very difficult to overturn a conviction
we're happy for him these stories make a
difference well Aaron thank you a
reminder about great journalism great
work there